have you ever seen the list I haven't
seen it in a couple of years of ten
things that if two or three of these
things happen to you in a short period
of time you for the stress related to it
would likely put you in the hospital
it's stuff like filing bankruptcy or
getting a divorce or the death of a
child or having your house burned down
one of the most stressful and
emotionally it's one of the top ten
stressful and emotionally draining
things that can happen it's your home
it's your memories it's your stuff that
gives you comfort your wedding pictures
your baby pictures etc etc the videos of
Christmases from ten years ago if you
hadn't backed them up somewhere and your
house burns down gone 14,000 homes
that's more homes than a lot of you have
in your community
it'd be like your entire community our
county that we're in I bet doesn't have
14,000 homes it might but I don't know
but it's it that's like wiping out an
entire county in some areas that's
what's happened in California the
campfire is California's deadliest most
destructive wildfire in history the news
channels have moved on and they're
talking about other things they find
something trivial in politics to go
bananas over 14,000 homes are gone
eighty-five people have been killed at
least 296 people still unaccounted for
it's a hundred and fifty three thousand
acres destroyed by fire
the woolsley fire in Southern California
destructive as well Napa last year got
it as well this is a really devastating
hit I mean this is like Katrina hitting
the Gulf Coast hitting Texas I mean it's
just unbelievable the devastation is so
thorough and that leaves folks just in
in a kind of emotional shock and we
certainly are praying for you guys we
understand what you're facing and I'm
starting to get a handful of questions
coming in by email from people in that
area and so what do you do if you face
complete destruction and a hurricane
fire or some kind of tornado those kinds
of situations what do you do in those
situations because it's not like you're
you know three to six months emergency
fund is going to take care of all that
right
hopefully you're in a position with that
kind of destruction that you have
insurance and hopefully the insurance
company that they generally load up you
know entire truckloads of claims
adjusters to go to these areas a lot of
them are subcontracted even because they
you know they move around and do this
but they're trying and a lot of them are
trying to do a good job and some of them
aren't trying to do a good job so what
do you do if the insurance company isn't
cooperating well you know the first
thing you're going to do obviously is
document every step of the way and the
number of contacts you've had with them
and continue to climb the ladder up into
the supervisors and so forth to try to
get you know your basic needs covered
because they're required to cover that
in almost every policy if ultimately you
cannot get your insurance company on a
homeowner's claim of this size
that you know to behave you've kind of
got two options you can get an
independent claims adjuster that works
for you and get them to work on your
behalf
and or hire an attorney now what you've
got to do in these situations where they
get you and honestly I've been around
the fires not not where there's 14,000
homes knocked out but where a customer
has lost a home and they've gotten us
involved from the financial coaching
perspective enough to know that sadly
they like the insurance companies you
know they really do not intend to pay
out everything that's due and you pretty
much have to make them in a lot of cases
now there's some of them that do a good
job but I think if you assume right off
the bat that you're dealing with
rattlesnakes it'll keep you from being
bitten you can still be nice and kind
and all that but and you can be
persistent but I think you assume that
there's things that you don't know so a
certified public adjuster is one way to
get some representation on your side but
listen you've got to go back and if you
have any copies of videos if you video
the inside of your house for instance
for inventory purposes which is always a
good idea for everyone to do and you
keep that off-site at your bank you know
or keep it somewhere other than that and
a fireproof safe doesn't work in a fire
of this type a fire of this type is so
hot it'll melt a safe okay
I mean you're not gonna go in there and
find video that works in something they
got got that hot it's not gonna work I
mean a hard idem might survive inside a
safe like that but it's not going to
you're not going to find video that
hasn't got that's gotten that hot and it
works so anyway the point is you've got
to make detailed copious lists of
everything and you just sit and think of
everything in every closet on every wall
every nook and cranny every item is
covered
and then you know once we get the check
how do we best use the insurance money
well you've got to decide if you're
going to rebuild or not if you had a
mortgage on the property the check will
be made out if you have a mortgage on
your home the check will be made out to
you and the mortgage company and it'll
be used to rebuild you'll be hiring a
contractor in conjunction with your
insurance company to rebuild or it's
used to pay off the mortgage if you want
to do that and you own a lot you own you
know a subdivision lot which a lot of
people will own a lot of subdivision
Lots so not going to be that great a
thing to have that right now they should
we take out the FEMA loans if we need to
only as an absolute last resort try to
do everything to avoid that it sounds
like it's wonderful but it is a loan
then it has to be paid back and it'll
bite you later if our mortgage company
offers forbearance should we take it
only if you have to because all they're
doing is delaying the inevitable which
is payments the payments are put on the
back end so it's again it's kind of like
borrowing money so if you can pay your
payment's keep paying your payments
because you're not gonna get it as a
discount it's going to be stuck on the
back end you're gonna end up paying it
so don't do that unless you have to in
these cases